in terms of
the things that i'd like to cover
overall in this talk um first of course
i want to introduce the project uh it's
history and context which i hope will
kind of clear up a lot of the uh
questions that i i made about kind of
you know
where when when there's these two kind
of options where rust comes down on one
side i hope i can i can kind of clarify
some of that to give you an idea of what
i mean um
and in particular some of the
participant pain points that
organizations like mozilla had to
contend with in their code bases and why
it led to the creation of russ um
expanding upon you know rus extant
context i want to talk about some of the
key trade-offs that russ makes and where
it comes down on a number of issues
while actually introducing you to the
rust code and syntax
project layout basic tooling etc um also
for any of you who are actually already
familiar with rust like if you're
expecting to show up and you know shoot
the breeze um
and and you know talk about a bunch of
advanced rust stuff uh you know that
rust is a huge language
um and so i really can't even cover like
really even 40
of the languages actual features i can
kind of talk about what i think are kind
of the most basis basic structural
things on top of which we can build
enough knowledge to talk about the
functional topics that i want to cover
in this talk and that was kind of what i
was going for um and if there's stuff
that i miss or if there's topics that i
introduce kind of out of nowhere then
that's my bad just stop and let me know
and i'll do my best to expand upon that
my goal of course is to give you guys
something useful that you can take away
from this
um
of course you know like i said the
promised thing in the title a discussion
of functional programming and rest
itself i wanted to highlight it because
it's actually it's funny it's actually
just one part of the talk and there's a
bunch of other stuff you know that ends
up kind of coming up and overruling that
um
i wanna also talk about um you know in
context for rust uh i wanna present some
entry points for different kinds of
programming where rust is popular um for
anybody you know who wants to do certain
kinds of things whether it's game dev or
embedded programming um you know just
kind of provide some pointers for where
you can go to find out more information
um there's a couple of things i think
that are really exciting about the
future
of you know stable rust i should say
because there's all kinds of wild stuff
in the nightly builds but much of it
never makes it out
or will stay in the nightly builds
forever um just because of the nature of
it so that some of the things that are
making it into you know that the stable
main branches are is going to be really
cool so i'm excited about that
um
the first i want to just really really
quickly kind of talk about rust in brief
um rust is multi-paradigm which is to
say it accommodates a more
object-oriented style where data-bearing
structures manage their internal state
via methods
you know the way that we have kind of a
concept of structures holding data
matched forward to methods or you know
doing certain kinds of like
inheritance-based polymorphism is
through what's called a trait system
which if you're familiar with haskell is
basically like haskell type classes
where you specify a trait and then you
have to implement that trait you
implement it kind of ends up being like
a three-way pivot between the
specification of the trait and then
implement a concrete implementation of
the trait for uh you know a data
structure and where you actually will
spell out methods and then you know you
can have default methods and so on that
are already defined um
you know those are features that you're
seeing that are leaking back up into
like you know.net core
with the default implementations on
interfaces
so that's pretty exciting um as well as
within rust accommodates more functional
styles you know that focus on things
like
immutability declarative patterns and
purity um in design um the classic
description
of the project of course is that it
pursues the trifecta of safety i would
say in safety in terms of memory access
that's a really important caveat and
that really needs to be emphasized
emphasized performance in this case
chasing a c plus like performance
profile and benchmarks which i think the
project has been pretty good about doing
and concurrency
which which i would point out is
subordinate to safety as anybody who's
done any amount of multi-threaded
programming and rust will tell you um
the compiler will get on you pretty
quick uh because it is a uh
is a harsh task master um
rust has a broadly c like syntax with
some conveniences like the fact that
many of the control flow structures like
if else are expression style so you can
use them like you would in like okay or
in an ml language where you can use ifs
basically to you know do conditional
values where things that you do in like
c with the ternary expressions so you
have um
but you know just more the idea that
like um
you know like that all blocks blocks
naturally become expression based so you
have things like return position becomes
important and you know things that like
you don't really think about if you're
programming in a c like language um but
that language is like even like you know
scala f sharp um and stuff like that
that kind of like you know even if
you're doing a more imperative style
things that fall out uh pretty naturally
um
a um
sorry just a sec um there are also other
nuances of the language uh it has an llk
grammar so some and some things that
fall out of that is that parentheses are
optional in um like control flow
structures like around ifs you don't
have to use parentheses but brackets
always end up being uh required for all
blocks um except for like single
expression uh closures or you know like
in inline specified uh you know
functions
um
and so you know because there's always
you know because there's always blocks
for control flow structures and you
don't have things like sentinel clauses
or accidental fall through uh there's no
case structures um another oh camel
influence worth noting is the compiler's
default allowance of shadowing variables
which is you know reclaim redeclaring
the same variable over and over even
though it has a different backing type
as you know it gets consumed and used um
that's something that you know it seems
to be like a more functional style and
and it becomes pretty useful in rust
when you're dealing with linear types
that you know you basically consume
and excrete new values over and over
uh rust is statically typed with the
rich type system that's most often
compared to haskell but it's worth
noting that it includes a few features
mostly because of the borrowing and like
value moving systems um that really like
only
can you match or surpass when you get
into dependently typed systems like coke
or agda um and so you know but that
being said of course haskell has you
know out of the box like higher kind of
types um you know that are expressible
in the language right now rust is coming
about with a way to have the same level
of expression but they're approaching it
from a different angle i would say
because i mean if you look at hkt you
understand that it requires basically
run time like there's a lot of runtime
stuff happening under the covers and so
with rust you don't necessarily have
that
a major goal of rust has also been to
expose what's commonly called a c-like
memory model which is usually shorthand
for something much closer to how a
processor actually works although you
don't you know get access to registers
and stuff um this is most important when
you compare rust against more pure
functional languages
who by their very design kind of require
pervasive uses of things like linked
lists and hidden heap allocations under
the covers and garbage collection
to kind of abstract away and you know
give you like a more pure environment to
work in um the goal for rust is to not
compromise on any memory access
functionality offered by cnc plus plus
and you know because rust also includes
a robust form function interface for
consuming exposing rust code to cnc plus
plus
um you know like those things being hard
constraints ultimately those are things
that kind of chew away at a lot of um
you know like the functional
conveniences that you see in other more
pure languages
um in line with above
you know like the focus on you know
performance
and you know
transparent memory access rest focuses
and you end up seeing it kind of blown
out in a lot of uh the standard library
types and of course library types
produced by vendors
is the focus on zero cost abstractions
and a lot of riaa i mean like resource
acquisition is initialization style
patterns that arise as a result so you
know if you're familiar with
particularly like c plus plus um
rust has got you there and it's still
there uh rust also boasts i would say
what i think is the most robust
developer tool chain out there um and
perhaps that if they're any dedicated
haskell or you know oh camel or go or no
developers who feel otherwise then i'm
sorry
reasonable minds can disagree on this i
hope so don't flame me too hard
um
moving on to talking about rust the
project itself uh it started out
initially as a a project of a gentleman
named graydon hoare um a canadian
developer who i believe he did undergrad
and math and then a masters in cs before
moving on to industry work uh most of
his work and his cv is around kind of
compilers and what he calls industrial c
plus plus so kind of working on like
high performance a high availability
high availability high availability
systems that because of implementation
needs need to move down lower down the
stack and away from you know virtual
runtime environments
um so that was kind of his experience
and then he ended up landing at uh
mozilla
um where you know the uh a major issue
for them is basically their
you know at this at that point i mean 15
years old give or take depending on how
you track the age of a mozilla going
back to you know its various
incarnations
um you know an old very mature very
large c c plus plus code base and then
dealing with uh you know basically
memory um related issues
and you know has that being a major
source of bugs and vulnerabilities and
for them and so
for him the motivation to make rust
would be summed up i guess like so and
this is paraphrasing a 2019 twitter
exchange that he had um he said he saw
rust as and i quote like throwing c plus
plus folks including myself a life raft
with regard to safety safety is the
thing the c plus plus we want to hit the
c plus plus niche but we want memory
safe and including including race for
three multi
race free multi threading and that's
hard
um and so
building kind of working on you know
that project he started with uh is if
the original rust uh compiler was done
in ocamel
and
while he was working on it at mozilla
they began sponsoring the project and
they helped put together a team of
researchers and particularly a gentleman
named nico matsasis who made what i
would say are some pretty critical
contributions that i'll get into a
little bit later i'm eventually the you
know with that you know with the team
together the core compiler was rewritten
and became self-hosting uh you know
before the project was announced in 2010
um and then between 2010 and its 1.0
release they iterated on a lot of
features including adding the like the
borrowing system didn't exist at the
time of the first alpha release and the
way that they were basically dealing
with memory safety was kind of with like
annotations that separated heap
allocated from like locally in thread
reference counted things from pure value
types
and they eventually iterated towards a
system that ended up being more like c
and c plus plus but had you know the
borrowing system included which itself
is kind of an extension of a cyclone if
you're familiar with that which was um a
c dialect a kind of experimental
research c dialect that had uh some
early versions of what you know would
become the borrowing of what you know
becomes the borrowing system in rust
um
so like i said um you know the including
the borrowing system um just making
changes to the language to hue even
closer to a true c plus plus memory and
runtime model
um the early version of the language
actually had like a a checked constraint
or contracts feature like where you
could put constraints on functions that
was removed um you know like i said tool
you know retooling of syntax references
boxes which are you know russ is rus
basically library type for dealing with
heaped heap values or you know memory
allocated on the heap um
and then of course the introduction of
mutability kind of as a core concept for
when you like at the time of specifying
a slot or a variable specifying
mutability and kind of the things that
fall out from that um all that was done
before reaching 1.0 in 2015 and since
the 1.0 release changes to rust have
been uh organized into three rolling
offerings there's a nightly version of
rust that's built and released of course
nightly uh based on the state uh the
passing state of the trunk um of the get
repository you know so if the main trunk
is passing then you know they'll they'll
release
um
they have a role rolling beta release
that base i believe it is updated every
six weeks and things that quote unquote
graduate out of the nightly they go into
the beta release
and then they're there and they'll stay
there for a while and then finally
there's a stable release that contains
features graduating out of the beta on a
rolling consistent six-week basis uh the
latest releases one is rust 1.56.1
this is a point release on the 1.56
to address a code formatting cve um if
you're it's not like a it's actually a
really interesting vulnerability i mean
if you go read the
1.56.1 announcement it points at them
basically they introduced with 1.5 6.0
um
allowing you to use like arbitrary
unicode for identifiers which wasn't a
thing before and so when you have um
arbitrary unicode and identifiers
there's ways to sneak in like basically
empty identifiers that would mess up the
code formatting uh based on whether it
was right to left or left to right and
so you could get this situation where
somebody could maliciously basically
pollute
the identifier spaces so that um
basically code when you looked at it as
a raw file versus when it was actually
compiled um
like it would actually look different in
different situations and so they have a
they did a release to address that um
and then finally rust also periodically
releases additions that represent
basically breaking changes compared to
previous editions so when russ 1.0 was
released russ 2015 was the addition that
was released at that time um regardless
of the version all prior editions will
be supported in the compiler and
individual crates opt into which edition
they support
the latest rust edition is 2021 which
like i said um or if i had mentioned it
it actually uh was debuted at the same
time as the most recent rust release
1.56 which was at the uh in late october
um as noted before um course rust is an
open source uh project and it's
developed out in the open on github um
they developed a lot of really amazing
build infrastructure and i'd say that um
it's a huge part of their project
expenses uh just running their build
infrastructure considering the amount of
stuff they're doing um and
just talking about contributing to rust
it could be its own discussion so if
that's something you're interested in or
learning more about the project
structure and kind of you know what all
is there and how you can get involved i
just recommend checking out russell
rustling.org to learn more
um of course origin rust was originally
owned as a project within mozilla but
has since been spun out and is now
governed by an independent nonprofit
that manages trademarks and copyrights
and provides a funding structure for
sponsors um i also read after i made
this
slide actually the new batch of sponsors
just joined this month
including arm and toyota or others i
don't know are there any are there any
misra miserasy programmers here anybody
know what i'm talking about any good
stuff any any embedded folks tonight no
okay yeah so it's interesting that an
auto manufacturer is coming on because
what they have right now for the state
of the art for auto programming is
pretty pretty gnarly um if you're
curious like i said look up look up
mizracy m-i-s-r-a um
and so uh since before the 1.0 release
the rust team has been doing most of
their feature development out in the
open through a public rfc process where
the community members suggest features
kind of as an internet in a standardized
essay format and they have a place to
kind of discuss and debate about that
and then also you know the the rfcs
themselves kind of become tagged and
numbered so that they can be referenced
explicitly in a subsequent pull request
the rest government governance structure
um features a core team that oversees
the directions of the project and then
sub-team leadership
leadership of sub-teams and
cross-cutting concerns
sub-teams cover everything from the
compiler infrastructure
language features uh crate i o
management crates io is the website for
kind of the backing package system for
rust i won't have a lot of time to get
into the developer tooling but you know
bears mentioning that rust ships an
official supported package repository
akin to npm um but with many features
that are more appropriate to the fact
that it's shipping native code
and a lot of you know like dealing with
different platforms and so on um
and of course like i said dev tooling
community moderation releases etc
um so for next i want to dive into
talking about the key trade offs of russ
but first let's actually show some code
so what i'm going to do here
is i'm going to go
and actually just use the rust tooling
everybody can see my that's not too
small is it my powershell window
so i'm going to go ahead
it's pretty small okay
so
what i'm doing here is um is that a
little better
yeah
okay what i'm doing here is really
quickly just spinning up a new uh
did you chip it if i clawed a bigger
screen
well that is true
that is true
so really just really i use cargo which
is um rust basically package and project
management tool to initialize a new
project and so what it did was it spun
up this library and also it made it a
valid git repository um so that's here
and it's in place for us and then i just
opened a visual studio window um first
class rust tooling is available in vs
code if you want to
do that i would just install it i
recommend just getting the rust
extension
um
so what we get here is of course like i
said this is a git repository so they
give us kind of a get style um
you know get ignore and then the this
tamil file is basically the manifest and
if you're familiar with you know npm or
you know
applications or package routes this is
equivalent to you know the package json
um and so you can specify a lot of the
same stuff although it has a lot more um
stuff that is you know germane just to
rust
but in the actual source itself we
actually have the library and so what
they gave us here was just
this little um actually just a bit of
test code so really quickly what we have
here is this is a
basically a compiler directive that says
to only compile this code when we're
compiling for tests and so the compiler
will know whether it's compiling for a
build debug production or you know test
and it it does basically you know that
affects the size of the binary by
convention rust they don't have separate
libraries or even separate files usually
the tests are in line as freestanding
functions
alongside where actual implementation is
that's just kind of by convention that's
the way that you know they've done it
so really quick though i just want to go
ahead and
make a make a
function that does a thing
and uh go ahead and then
oh whoops
excuse me
and use it um
so here just really here really quickly
within this function uh
we can go we can see
i can do once again i can use the cargo
tooling and it'll go ahead and it runs
this one out of the box test
so
i want to go ahead and just use this
and i want to go
and i want to run it
oh whoops i did not save
whoa what's this about it's complaining
it says it can't find this function in
scope what's that about well it turns
out that what i need to do
[Music]
in order to make use of this is i
actually have to import this thing
in and so in order to get that to work
so that kind of brings us to the first
lesson of rust
which is that um
rust really favors explosion over
succinctness
that is the rust compiler will almost
always push you towards explicitly
spelling out your
expectations it does it assumes very
little um and most of the stuff where it
does assumptions is for convenience
around managing references and values um
but for almost everything else um they
you know the compiler will make you pay
if you uh if you don't spell it all out
uh and i'd say you know as part of that
rust already has a reputation um
brightly earned for having a really uh
dense syntax with a lot of gotchas from
the compiler and this is i mean of
course part of the design of the
language um so if you don't like it i
mean this is kind of where it's at i
doubt it's going to get much simpler
your alternatives are probably swift or
maybe haskell i don't know so have at it
i'm kidding of course i know there are
lots of there actually are lots of other
platforms like um the guy who gave the
presentation a couple months back
talking about elm and his platform he
was working on you know so there's a lot
of people are kind of tackling you know
what rust is doing from different angles
although i would say that uh that link
that that platform was a lot more
loosely typed than rust so
um
next uh none of the next key tradeoffs
with rust of course and i've hinted at
this a lot um
is that uh performance over convenience
and so rust by its nature really really
cares about performance its history as a
mozilla project meant that you know for
them to be able to replace parts of the
mozilla browser which itself as i
mentioned is a massive c plus code base
that's what they wanted to do with it
and so what they had to be able to do
was you know have
transparent memory access and give
developers tools to reason about how
intensive their programs will be which
you know almost 95 percent of the time
comes down to really just being able to
mem reason about memory allocations and
if you can get that down and you can
tighten that up um that's where you know
the lines share of uh of
optimizations and code bases come
and this is of course is because rust
doesn't do much magic under the hood um
with memory allocation and so kind of to
demonstrate this this table that i have
here um i've included it from the
embedded rust book which is actually
really cool if you go out and google it
rust embedded um i believe as or just
yeah rust embedded or the rust embedded
book they've got an online document for
it uh and this this table outlines the
impact of marking your crate and so
that's uh when i talk about marking the
crate that would be within that cargo
tomml file which i mentioned is the
manifest
specifying um no std and so what that
means is basically building this the
crate your dependency whether it's an
application or a library without any
dependencies on the rus standard library
and so what you can see here what you
get when you when you do no std is you
basically you lose keep allocated types
and so things that build on top of heap
allocation so specifically there's some
mem alec uh a method within there that
does you know for doing heap allocations
um the things that build upon that in
the library like vectors which is
basically
uh
where you would use like a linked list
you know just an infinitely expanding
list although the implementation is
different um from the linked list so
it's not fair to call it that but you'd
use it basically in the same way um or
hash maps which is like their equivalent
of a dictionary type
you basically don't have access to any
of that you can see stack overflow
protection
gets stripped out
there is some
there's certain way certain libraries
are dependencies where you can specify
initialization code which will actually
be ran before the main entry point of
the program that goes away
and then of course the standard library
which is you know the majority um
of you know the officially supported
code is within there but there's a
smaller library called libcore that has
basically all uh stack allocated types
and abstractions that is still available
and
what you get when you strip away the
standard library is a massively smaller
um binary that is appropriate for using
when you're writing firmwares
doing firmware code or kernels or
yeah bootloader stuff
so you know the fact that that's
possible in rust is kind of a testament
to kind of where you know they're going
because
we take it for granted that languages
like c just do that out of the box
because they were purpose built for that
because of the era in which they were
built in the abstractions that were you
know at the time of c's debut is
considered incredibly high level but
nowadays what c considers high level is
actually really low level for what us as
application developers deal with so to
come back and actually approach that and
take that problem on to be able to meet
it there um requires a lot of stuff that
you know you have to think about and
deal with um that you know isn't obvious
at first you think oh this would be easy
i can i could do you know
you know like any anything more
complicated than a fourth interpreter
basically it gets really hard
um
so
the next um item of course i i mentioned
you know with key trade-offs and rust is
memory safety um memory safety is really
really important and so pretty much when
anybody's talking about safety and rust
really they're just talking about memory
safety and so that and that's it's
pretty important to kind of grasp that
um
and you know there's some things kind of
that i'll hint at and and and talk about
in this uh
talk that um
i i gloss over but i just want to
re-emphasize so things like move types
uh value consumptions they s they
constitute what's called a linear type
like in type theory which means
basically like a thing that's there or
not and you know it specifies that like
as part of a types life cycle you
include the concept of it being consumed
and being destroyed and so with that um
and how it complements the borrowing
lifetime system in rust
it natural patterns arise that kind of
allow developers to design systems that
i think you know include that kind of
safety
um and then also
examples um that i show in this talk
with closures and like you know lambda
methods basically they allied a lot with
how rust distinguishes between pure
functions and closures within code and
you know the difference between pure
function and closure is closures capture
values out of their enclosing lexical
environment and they incorporate that as
part of their value for their lifetime
so that has implications for you know um
in a in a language where um you do
manual memory management that don't come
up in garbage collected languages um if
any of you i don't know if any are there
c plus or modern c plus developers here
um you know that when they introduce the
lambda syntax there's also a pretty
heavy syntax for captures and how
captures happen um and so rust also has
to account for some of that stuff um but
anyway the the important thing is that
that because of memory safety because of
the borrowing system there's a subtle
and difficult to reason about issues
that can arise um
particularly when working with higher
order functions and i will get into some
of that
i do have a question about the
borrow system
if i remember correctly
um
there there's only you can have multiple
writers and one reader is that the
is that the situation you're talking
about for referencing for mutable versus
immutable references
yeah it's the so it'll be the other way
around and it depends on what's
happening so if there are mutable
references held
then you can't take a mutable reference
because
you might mutate it out from somebody
but when um
or excuse me it's the other way around
so you can hold you can hold multiple
immutable references but only a single
mutator at a time
and then um if immutable reference is
held then new immutable references won't
be allowed okay
um i guess wrapping up on this with the
trade-offs and you know if you imagine a
continuum with the land of calculus on
the left-hand side and machine
instructions on the right
for me rust comes down somewhere in the
center right
like i said it includes and talk and a
lot of stuff in its type system and
conveniences that are obviously
descended from the ml line of languages
and as i mentioned um besides c plus
plus uh grading horror himself is a big
o camel guy
um
but uh in the end again and again where
it has to russ always goes on the side
of basically coming down more towards c
and c plus plus as it as it has to do
with memory management um and so for
that reason there's a bunch of kind of
you know you kind of end up kicking the
box out from underneath a bunch of
functional stuff that you'd have
otherwise
so
next um i'm going to go ahead and do a
whirlwind tour of rust syntax and
features
and so
i'm going to talk about all these items
i'm just going to kind of blow through a
source code file that i have kind of set
aside for this
to talk about these things so first we
have control flow and so as you see here
you know ifs the blocks are always there
but there's no parens that are necessary
um and you know basically c style if if
and else we
we have here is basically um expression
style use of if and else to capture a
value out of it the compiler will look
and verify you know it does all the type
the type stuff to make sure you don't
return you know uh you know type type f
out of another one and type t out of the
other you know so you have to match all
that stuff up you get all that for free
of course because this is a statically
typed language you know all of these
things even though you don't specify
explicit type um you can get pretty far
in rust without having to specify the
type at the point of uh when you where
you define variables but occasionally it
becomes the thing if there's you know
enough ambiguity in what it is that's
being done
um
next we want to talk about uh closures
of course so this is um the syntax right
here for just a basic closure you can
see that has multiple statements it
doesn't emit any uh return values
and um
it has no input so if there was values
in here like this would be you know
this would become an input value that
would need to be provided
um but what it does show is it shows
capturing out of the environment and so
this is a closure this isn't a pure
function because it doesn't take any
inputs it doesn't return any output so
it's kind of a black box what it does i
mean by that buyer there kind of you
know questions whether it could be pure
but it also is capturing this value out
of here and it's doing this by taking
immutable reference to this already
stored mutable value um and of course in
terms of stuff that russ does for free
if that mute went away from after the
let keyword then suddenly this is an
immutable value and we can't take
immutable reference to that so this kind
of gives a hint to kind of how
rust deals with mutability at the point
of slot definition so like if you have a
structure that has values within it um
those values themselves don't have their
mutability specified it's always
at the point of the the exterior storage
of the enclosing type and so you know
you can have basically cascading um you
know hierarchies arise out of that there
are some library types that are meant
kind of to do or to allow you to have
that kind of by their nature and design
allow basically side effects to leak out
of what looks like an immutable type
and that mostly happens with like unsafe
code under the cover under the covers
and it's kind of in you know limited
circumstances um
but like i said here with this example
you can see this is a closure capturing
a value and then doing a mutation on it
it has to this right here is it
dereferencing the value because this is
a reference of course
um and then so that it can mutate it and
then coming down here actually you know
executing
that that type or that that uh you know
function that was specified here this
closure and then being able to look at
you know its value before and after
um
next i want to talk really briefly about
kind of array types so one of the things
that's notable about them is that uh
their length is a part of their value
specification and i guess also speaking
really briefly i didn't i mean talking
about basic syntax so let is of course
you know familiar with ocam you're not
specifying a type this is the variable
name if you're specifying the explicit
type it follows after with the colon
like so and then this of course is uh
initialization uh rust is you know one
of those languages that will let you
initialize empty values there's no
concept of a null value within the core
link within the safe core language
itself so everything needs to be
initialized and it validates that um
here you can see this is basically
different syntax for initialization like
if you wanted to just
you know build out an empty 500 element
array you can see how you can do that or
you can specify each individual item or
of course you know at runtime of course
you're going to have different values um
you know they're going to be dynamically
constructed
but it's interesting to note that like i
said that um length is a part of array
type specification and so this right
here this is a this is a stack allocated
type
um is what that is
and so of course we have normal uh
indexing into arrays and then we have
typical uh you know types um or you know
basically convenience helper functions
out of the standard library um you can
see that uh
the arrays are stack allocated so we can
basically look at the memory footprint
of it and actually see that it's going
to be
size event 32 times 500 or whatever
um and then we get into kind of a basic
example of borrowing
so i mentioned this before up here with
this uh
you know this constitutes a borrow
taking a reference to this thing and so
borrowing refers to the system of the
compiler
it's it's referencing system but it's
accounting for all references taken and
it's making making sure that any
reference taken
doesn't violate mutability constraints
placed upon the type it makes sure that
any references taken that the value
where the reference is taken isn't
released while a reference is held
you know a bunch of things that ensure
kind of the soundness and memory safety
guarantees of the language so what this
ends up being is a slice which you know
a reference referring to and so this is
a special type annotation so it looks
like the array but it doesn't have the
length specification as part of the type
signature and it just has this to
specify so this is it just lets you know
that this is some amount of elements
of type i32 and then it's able to work
upon them here
another thing that's interesting of
course is that because
array types are static at the time of
definition you can see that
this particular definition of this type
xs
this is invalid because you know it only
has five elements so with a zero based
array index this is a beyond so
that's kind of just you know showing
what it is there um next i want to talk
about enums it's funny kind of enums
popped up before uh talking about
structs and so you can kind of construct
more cons you know more complex types
out of complex combinations of the two
but um enums of course are you know
algebraic data types uh if you're
familiar with them from uh you know f
sharp o camel and haskell you know
they're there it's these are kind of
basic enums but of course enums can be
have like arbitrary density or
complexity um this is an example uh so i
mean really quick you can see you know
kind of the ways that
you can do pattern matching that arises
off of enums that's kind of really the
intro you know exhaustive pattern
matching um
israel is is probably one of the main
things and the destructuring that you're
allowed to do out of that um
and you know you want and and and of
course enums are also like in memory
they're they're similar to attacked
unions in c so basically what they carry
is you know a region that's the size of
the largest enum variant and then a tag
and then it knows basically to swap out
the contents based on what the current
variant is
um but in memory you know they look
basically like c unions with an
additional tag
um
this is an example of a slightly more
complex list that pretty much mimics
like a cons style
um you know linked list where the the
enum can have two possible values it's
either
um
this contents of itself which is its
current value and then a box which is
you know keep allocated value pointing
to the next item in the linked list and
that thing itself can either be another
one of these
or it can be a nil value specifying the
end of the list
um so that's kind of an example you know
how um
you know ways that enums can be used but
i mean really like edoms arise um in
systems like you'll see a lot of like i
don't know error types that are
manifested as enum so that each variant
can carry custom information um you know
if you have a uh you know tc you know
tcp packet processor the variants might
be different kinds of high you know pac
uh packet packet protocols built on top
of tcp um you know the sky's the limit
and so of course if you guys uh come
from
uh a functional programming background
particularly in haskell or f sharp or o
camel then that is uh nothing new um
moving on of course we have structs as
well which are pretty much more uh
c-style memory layout um data structures
so those are really um straightforward
you can also have what are called unit
structs which basically function as like
atoms they have no value except for
themselves or like a c or like an enum
with only a single variant um is another
way to think about them
um and then you can also have tuple
values where you don't care about the
names or identifiers of them you just
care about them as basically you know
ordered
combinations of values which will
destructure at some point in the future
um i haven't shown it really here but uh
rust includes robust destructuring
syntax like you would do in haskell or
ocam or f sharp um so you know taking
apart values and then all of the um
destructuring capability exists in the
pattern matching system itself and as
time goes on rust seems to get they're
actually putting a lot of work into kind
of making the pattern matching system
itself more robust and more convenient
to use
but that stuff is totally like i don't i
don't have time to cover that
unfortunately i'm already over time
and moving on to the next item
i wanted to talk about the bar kind of
give a practical example of the
borrowing system itself so this function
itself kind of constitutes uh kind of a
discussion of kind of gotchas with the
borrowing system so when we start out
with this we're creating two values one
of them is a boxed value that just
contains an integer
um if you're i guess you know f sharp
and no camel style kind of annotations
you can also do stuff like uh
excuse me
you know like that and said to have
instead of commas for breaking up large
numeric values um
and then but rust has for its type
literals basically uh you know i32 u32
and 64 etc
and those things are you know they come
out naturally in the expressions of the
types there's no you know there's no
platform dependent like whatever the
platform says a number is like that
thing how there is in c where you can
have 16 or 32 or 64 bit integers
depending on the platform standard so
here we lay out these two values one is
boxed and one's placed on the stack um
and then
this these this all these methods do
is basically just exist to kind of
demonstrate uh what they would do with
these things so with the
with the function signature of this this
borrowed i32 value
it is a reference that's been taken to
this thing
and contrast that against this ebox i32
what it does is it takes this by value
and so it says this function takes
ownership of the box because of the way
that this is annotated it's taking the
box by value so whenever this is called
that value goes away so here we have
some examples of how we can see we can
borrow and work on these values
maybe do them use them for subordinate
you know calculations or whatever and
you know
these
these methods save memory because they
just do pointer access to this thing
that lives on a higher level higher
frame of the stack instead of having to
pass it by value and copy it into their
own stack or something like that so you
know there's that convenience there
and then within this nested block
we see
doing some things like here that boxed
value which you know it represents a
heap allocated value but it exists as a
value um
to have a reference taken to it and so
that reference can be used within here
but if we did something like this like
uncommenting this method right here and
ate it
then what happens is this boxed um value
it would be destroyed at this point or
it'd be consumed and not not you know
emitted out and so this breaks right now
because that subsequent
call to try and borrow it but it becomes
this becomes legal once you know that's
commented out also subsequently because
of that this call now is no longer valid
because
the this boxed value is already eaten up
here
so these are all things that are
basically happening just because of um
oops
i am common to the wrong line
these are things that are happening
because of russ borrow checking system
and pretty much all it's doing is you
know validating um that what you're
doing with variable what you're doing
with you know values and their variables
and how you're referring to them that
all of it basically ties out within the
current context and it's able you know
to do this across functions and you know
across function call boundaries and then
you know basically
to the entire boundaries within a crate
and then doing whole program analysis
when it actually links a program
together to you know enforce these
constraints
um
next uh i want to talk briefly about
traits like i said this is how you kind
of this is how you do like inheritance
polymorphism on what you would do with
classes in c sharp or with um you know
type classes which the
rest traits are almost exactly like
you're able to basically specify the
trait and say here's the behavior i want
implemented you can provide default
implementations these can also be you
know overridden in implementers um
the rust provides the ability to do like
a bear implementation just against a
structure itself so these will be
basically tight these will be methods
that will be available when you're
interacting with the concrete type
itself if this was cast or type into you
know cast or boxed into just the trait
then there would be basically those
things aren't available you know so this
is you know kind of you know
encapsulation and hiding uh
functionality and then finally we have
the implementation of the animal trait
for a sheep
basically with the defining of methods
that do things on the sheep itself
um
all of this is kind of you know really
noisy but just to kind of demonstrate
like i said they're kind of this
three-way pivot and so it's interesting
where you know you either have to own a
concrete type or the trade itself in
order to do anything useful so if you
have like a library type and you have
that and you know you and there's a
trait that you wanted to have it
implement like
you know that the challenge to be able
to do that um it kind of becomes tricky
based on where things are and so it's
you know you you're expected to be able
to have like
in you know
interior ownership of either a trait or
a concrete type um
and then uh finally
oh no excuse me that was just a thing
for that okay ready to move on so that
was kind of like i said just kind of a
quick um overview of the syntax was
there anything here that was like really
puzzling or weird to anybody i know i'm
covering a whole bunch of stuff and i'm
moving really fast is there any
questions before i move on
sure uh just a real quick question um
can the implementations i mean do they
have to
i guess
you said you had to own either the uh
trait or the class so can the
implementations occur in like other
files so if i import
like
type animal from a from a target like
from a
you know a
package and then i can implement
that
or i could implement or i could import
sheep and then implement animals in my
uh no it's at the crate boundary and so
you can't pull in someone else's you
know crate and then you know because
it's like if there's like a library that
you want that has a trait and then some
some other you know library that you
want to implement that trait for like
you don't own either of those things so
you have to ask one or the other
basically you know to
yeah
okay cool thanks
all right finally
um so we can talk about a functional
rust now we're here we're here to the
meat of it last um so in order to talk
about functional rust we have to kind of
set some boundaries around what exactly
is functional functional
so for this i'm going to kind of give
the hand wavy answer of saying that um
there are certain principles which make
code more functional some languages make
this easier or harder to adhere to and
generally speaking languages that make
it easier to adhere to functional
principles are considered functional
languages and even if
they do that though they often um they
make it harder to violate these
functional principles but however you
know almost always there's some way for
you to do it
to break you know functional principle
principle encapsulation or whatever you
want to call it uh if the situation
demands it um but
in general we have these things that we
say if a language or a system is more
like this or it supports this then we
consider it more functional and so those
things are i guess really briefly i
would say mutability um you know having
to do with kind of how you treat values
and how they're changed and how you know
they are applied within functions i
would say recursion is an important part
of it and then also of course i would
say higher order functions um and kind
of function pipelining uh become you
know are are things that are kind of
like you know they really play out a lot
in in functional languages and kind of
become core things
so with that in mind um
i would say talking about mutability um
i mean just looking at excuse me some of
the previous examples like where we
talked about with the borrowing system i
think that it's pretty self-evident that
you know rust has strong controls around
immutability of course it allows you to
break those you know rules or just to
make things mutable um
but out of the box and the behavior um
you know it's perfectly possible to
write pure functions in pure programs uh
in rust you know because of just you
know the
the the basic building blocks are there
um next when i talk about recursion i'll
just say really quick uh rust doesn't
have any tail call optimization
um so if you want to do a system where
you're gonna where you would have
something like some implement you know
infinite um recursion um you will you
can and will very much get stack
overflows like this example here shows
um you absolutely you know will blow up
in this case because this will just
recurse until it runs out of stack
um
you know and uh
you don't really need to implement your
own trampoline which is uh the way you
know that like you kind of do a
recursion like
functionality in systems that don't have
it
um because we have rust has what are
called iterators which is pretty much a
trait and language support feature for
doing iteration over um you know values
that are that are
amenable to be iterated over and the way
that it's implemented it allows you to
kind of have like dynamic infinite
objects or objects that block the next
time you try to go to an iteration or
something like that so that you'd end up
doing a lot of the things
that you would when you use recursion as
a control flow mechanism
in functional programming um and then of
course talking again about higher order
functions um
you know this is kind of the idea right
that where you pretty much just compose
pipelines of functions working on values
and mutating them until eventually you
get the thing you want and so this is
kind of an idiomatic example of how you
know you would take
you know create create a value from 0 to
100 and then you know double those
and then sum them back together and so
you can kind of see i just i had just
kind of the haskell golf
um parlor trick version of this to put
it alongside what you would do in rust
to show that while it is a bit more
verbose um it's
uh you know pretty close and that being
said i'll say that a lot of the cool
stuff that you're used to if you're
doing a lot of hardcore um like
statically typed functional program and
also i'll say this as a haskell baby um
i'm i'm pretty new to haskell i mostly
come to it through elm and i've wanted
to do more um but i'm i'm still i'm
still on that journey but uh a lot of
stuff that you you know would do
idiomatically in those languages like
currying doesn't exist um like point
free style like uh like pipelining um
doesn't exist in rust so you do kind of
you know the the same tools aren't there
kind of to use higher order functions in
um
in like really you know
i i guess like intention revealing and
declare in more declarative ways because
russ makes you do a lot more gate
bookkeeping and also the thing i
mentioned earlier about memory safety
enclosures um it's really easy when
you're working with closures so these
are these are all just pure functions
these are like these are reified as
function pointers at runtime they don't
have any any additional state
um with them because they don't capture
anything out of enclosing uh context but
as soon as you start having things where
like it really makes sense to do that
and you start capturing stuff it becomes
really hard to actually use a closure
and so um
you have to kind of fall back to a
couple of things like generic traits and
methods that consume them um
and it kind of you know it it gets
complicated and it limits utility and
this kind of plays into the memory
safety and uh especially once you get
into like multi-threaded programming
because almost any like
you know like i can see your people like
ultimately in any language you know or
any asynchronous back end when you want
to spawn a new thread or some kind of
background process you say run this
function pointer basically is what it
always comes down to and so in rust at
the point where you have to pass that
function pointer if it's not you know
just a bare function pointer then things
get complicated so that's where you know
like if you're trying to capture
anything you know useful um
that's that's the situation that rises
and rusts where you know i think
developers end up having their hands
tied
and then last um like i said kind of you
know because recursion isn't there what
we see instead is um iterators and so
this right here is just the declaration
of a vector so this is a special
shorthand form for declaring a vector
which is a rust name for like a linked
list or a dynamically expanding list um
with what they would be in other
languages
and so then this is kind of the natural
way to iterate over them but what's
happening here actually is this is all
de-sugared syntax
um for basically doing this
and so
if you if you you know kind of
this stuff right here this is kind of
what it actually looks like at runtime
and so what we're doing here with this
vector is we're turning it into an
iterator and we're you know making it
mutable of course in the process and
then
um you have to iterate over it in that
process
and so this while is pretty much
simulating that process this next um
returns
uh an option and so this let sum is
actually kind of is is a is a sort of um
it's a it's a sort of conditional
expression that's saying while the
result of of this next call is a sum
value because this actually returns an
option which is a sum or a none of t
and so this says while
while this iterator.next call is
returning a sum and this is the value
that's bound for use within this block
um keep running this while loop but once
this next reaches the end it'll return a
none and then this this loop would break
out so that's kind of that's kind of
like what this boils down to and so just
looking at that and seeing that you can
kind of see that you know taking this
syntax and kind of boiling it down to
just this is a win and you can also see
that within this natural form a lot of
opportunities to do kind of neat tricky
stuff arise where you know the iterator
is actually like something that's
blocking on external input or you know
incoming packets and a server or stuff
like that like there's a lot of you know
stuff and those are the same places um
where you would see like uh like lazy
evaluation used in haskell
all right so that was functional rust
all right so
with that out of the way i wanted to
talk a bit um about kind of like how you
would um how people are using rust in
different contexts so um rust is really
i mean popular and i think a lot of
people come to it in the context of uh
like back-end services that are doing a
lot of um like data work low-level io or
lots of like um you know like dsp type
stuff and these are things that i think
a lot of people before now we're doing
in node.js but kind of they hit the
limits performance-wise particularly
around like dsp work um
that you know
you see where naturally if they wanted
to go away from you know a high level
async i o engine like node they would
have to move their next place to go
would basically be to c um you know so
now like rust is becoming more popular
in that space um of course there's a lot
of like if you got anybody here is into
like blockchain technology rust is you
know a lot of the um
newer like i would say like post
ethereum or the
the ethereum killer blockchains are
coming out a lot of them like uh um
solana um are uh having you know rest
support as kind of a first-class thing
so that's pretty exciting
um
but there's other places where it's
rough more rough like
some of the tooling especially for like
using rust as web services are kind of
like more like you know application
level web services the tooling is there
but it's rough so like if you want to
use rust to stand up a restful api with
jot authentication you'll have a lot of
stuff that you're going to have to you
know stumble over especially once you
come into dealing with you know
integrating with your actual uh you know
security or your actual authentication
provider whatever that is um you know
like in a robust modern infrastructure
you're not you know the way that we do
authentication a lot of that tooling
is is still not great in my opinion and
for raw web application work i mean rust
itself doesn't have a lot to offer over
something like nginx serving up you know
app you know like an angular application
so you know it's it it's not a big win
there in that space in my opinion but i
some people insist on using it um that
way but i think that hopefully once the
tooling gets better particularly around
web services i hope that you know rust
will become a good option especially
because of how expressive the type
system is uh rust is on the other hand
seeing a lot of uh
uptake and developer tooling um
especially in the web application
infrastructure space uh if anybody is
you know really into web application
development next js
um has rewritten their pretty much their
tooling stack on top of rust command
line tools rome um which is the
successor to the babel transpiler if
you're familiar with that you know it's
kind of one of the first typescript
transpilers or excuse me like es 2015
transpilers that was out there you know
that was providing ways to kind of you
know write more modern uh versions of
javascript and then spit them out and
you know more browser consumable forms
um so rome the success for successor to
babel uh written by the same author he
is using rust for that and there's a lot
of others deno swc and parcel um a lot
of like uh i believe google not excuse
me not google but a cloud flare and
amazon both have um quick parsers when
you're like http http 3.0 uh parsers
written in rust um
so
if you want to learn more about that
there's a really good a pretty recent
blog post on the topic called rust is
the future of javascript infrastructure
that you can look at to learn more
of course rust has a lot of interest in
buzz and also hate i would say in the
game dev community
there really aren't any like big aaa
games that have shipped written in rust
but it definitely has a lot of interest
and there's some great tooling um that's
there i like to play around with engines
and there's tons of engines and stuff
like that to play with and rust
if you want to check out one in that you
could look at the bevy engine the bevy
and it's a really interesting kind of um
evented architecture um
for a rust game or you know like data
oriented um like an ecs system
um of course embedded programming
is a is a popular location thing i
talked about that earlier with the no
std annotation and kind of the
applications that you can get what the
impact of that is and of course while
rust is a challenge and more and you
know more space constrained like 8-bit
processors you know where it's hard to
even use c and you probably you know you
probably have fourth or just straight-up
machine code um rust is finding uptake
on you know platforms that have more
headroom
all the tooling and design is there to
embed rust in a way that just isn't
possible in most other languages like i
talked about because they're really
grasping with the consequences of trying
to have a really c memory compatible
language and dovetailing with the above
of course um the linux kernel itself is
starting to make space and recently
they've done some things to make it
possible to basically write drivers and
linux kernel modules in rust
chances are there won't ever be rust
itself in the linux kernel tree
because they're you know gpl three
people and rust is an mit code base but
i mean you know the rust code itself or
whatever you know
my understanding is that they're just
not super enthused about the idea of
starting to take on rust but vendors
will be able to start writing kernel
modules and shipping them with their
products or you know or individual
companies that you know if you're a
company that's a big enough deal to have
your own you know custom kernel modules
i think facebook google et cetera they
have the tools to be able to use this
um really quickly talking about the
future of um
rust some really cool things that are
coming down the pike um
so this is stabilization of a feature
called gats which is uh generic
associated types and so this is an
exciting addition that extends
associated types which is a it's a
feature that i didn't even talk about in
this talk that goes to show um i barely
even i didn't even really talk about
polymor you know like real tight
polymorphism that is available in rust
but um
associated types are a way to kind of
specify like a type slot on a trade
separate from like a generic constraint
itself and it just means that the
implementers have to specify that type
and then they can reference that type
within you know their implementation um
and so this is an extension to
associated types that allow you to have
additional uh generic annotations on top
of that which kind of gets us pretty
close to the idea of types that are
abstracted over there type a you know a
thing that can deal with a type that is
an abstraction over other extractions
itself so kind of you know like a a way
to chip at higher kind of types within
rust and then combining that with what
are um with a feature that's called
const generics
which refers specifically to allow
the embedding of const information
within a type
um as a dynamic parameter and so and
really quickly kind of to demonstrate
what that is like
um
in the example uh
over here where i was talking about um
the use of uh arrays so this is a this
is a a feature or you know a basically a
part of the type itself and so that
comes out as like you know
item of t
with you know a length of k
and so there are t items and they have a
k they have a length of k um
and so within within
these right here within arrays that the
type is a is a part of their um
their type definition but you can't
specify a generic type
or or like set a generic constraint
where you can say
you have a type of t and that
you know the the the length component
itself is a generic is a generic thing
that can be deferred until further on
and so um this isn't really the greatest
explanation for but the idea is that
they're making it so that you can have
you know generic um you can you can make
things that would be f that would be
size fixed at compile time like into
generic constraints so you can have like
basically
a type that represents um like a fixed
length of something and so that it'll be
pretty interesting for like what's
possible in the future and i think these
two things put together um are going to
kind of be what gets the community
towards you know being able to have the
expressiveness that a lot of folks are
looking for with higher kind of types
within rust so it's pretty exciting and
this stuff is kind of coming down the
pike hopefully like in the next year
we'll see it on the main branches
is there a concept of like uh generic
constraints on those where
yeah
you can say it's an implementation of
this
yeah you can
you can say t yeah i
i don't i don't think i have an example
but yes they're they're generic
constraints as as robust as you know
so with g-a-t could you for example say
um
uh this uh
say this function operates on um
an x of t where x is a
um
applicative
yeah
so the with gat itself this is going to
manifest the the annotation um for for
associated types it appears within
traits themselves so what it'll allow
you to do is write traits that abstract
over a type that itself abstracts over
an additional type
and you can place well and so
additionally so the the kind of the
thing as well and and something that i
completely didn't cover because like i
said there's just the space is too large
in the time that we have um you can also
place generic constraints around
lifetimes so you can set constraints and
you can carry lifetimes as generic uh
parameters themselves if you ever see
like a a lowercase letter preceded by a
dash within a within a generic
definition that's a that's basically a
lifetime constraint and so it's about
being able to put lifetimes
and um within a thing and so you can
specify a trait
that is like a t
that has a lifetime associated with it
that's pegged to some outside type
because that's mostly where like how
like within the borrowing system that's
kind of where lifetimes appear within
type annotations is so you can say the
type that i'm creating it's going to
carry it's going to contain this other
thing and i'm going to guarantee that my
type lives as long at least as long as
this thing does and you're kind of
you're giving the compiler that
information and so um that's a lot of
like what it's going to be used for but
um i mean yeah you wouldn't write a
function that way you basically would
write a trait they would have that gat
specification and then it's going to
have methods on specified on it that do
those things and then a concrete type
comes along and implements that and kind
of fills it fills the rest out although
it might still be generic for its t
right so you know because that's the the
higher kindness of it
until it's actually applied it runs
until it's applied by a consumer you
know who actually fills out the inner
the inner type
um yeah i guess so that gets into
question so this is the end
um if i had uh any recommendations it
would be uh to check out the
rustling.org website um it's incredibly
robust and a great gateway uh if you
want to actually interact with the
community the first place i would
recommend going and maybe this is a
generational thing i don't know but i
would recommend going to the discord
they have a huge community there there's
like like it's it's like it's like a
like a mass like an irc network level
you know large in terms of how many
people are there and active and um you
know a lot of the a lot of the core team
are there and you know i don't know if
actual development work happens there i
believe that the the rust organization
itself maintains a separate chat system
off of discord i forget the name um but
there's a lot a lot of stuff there
that's a great entryway there's of
course there's a reddit community that's
really active
you know if you spend any time on stack
overflow there's a lot of rust activity
there a very popular language on stack
overflow um so there's a lot of
opportunities of course
to interact and get involved with the
community